it's a free market economy but it's also
a national security issue
I tend to think of climate change as a
national security I do too they're not
going to be able to do it in time the
way they're doing in everything else and
adapt and okay
let's look at ourselves right now okay
let's say this road we're on is the
American political system
and you see past that bridge up there we
have to get past that bridge in the next
minute
except this is what we're stuck on
because we can't get there and you know
this as well as I do
I know people in their 20s and 30s that
will not have kids because they're like
I'm not going to subject a human being
to what's coming
do you think my children who are 15
years younger than that are somehow
going to go God I always wanted my kids
to grow up in Mad Max eating lizards off
the road and murdering their neighbors
to get a glass of water
I mean
things are going to break down
Wesley the passion that you and so many
others have on this is what gives me
hope in democracy and hope in the future
of the country that's what it's going to
take to make change happen
I think we're living in a rigged system
and I think it's very hard to break out
of that rigged system because Money
Talks
I drove down from San Francisco
yesterday on Highway 5 and it's bumper
to bumper for 300 miles on Highway five
and you think God that's just a small
part of it so we know in these big urban
areas like the Los Angeles Basin and
Metropolitan New York we know that we
live here for convenience we live here
because civilization works but we also
know it is relatively fragile it depends
on power it depends on water it depends
on food it depends on warehousing it
depends on security and people following
the rules and obeying the laws and it
only takes small disruptions to that
whether through natural disaster or
through climate change through organized
crime or through War
uh through exogenous forces
and and you'd see catastrophe
it's easy to see how things can fall
apart
long tunnels and outpitched dark
Communications and telephone systems
have collapsed on motorways cars simply
pull over if they find a place with a
signal
people now stand in line outside
supermarkets not to go in they're just
hoping that it will eventually open
sierto
Como community
[Music]
the combination of the weight of
scientific evidence and the Dynamics of
the financial system suggest
that in the fullness of time climate
change will threaten Financial
resilience and longer term prosperity
all the money in the world will not save
us once it starts to fail and then
people will discover that you can't eat
a flat screen TV and you can't eat a
German luxury car
what are we gonna do
it's War
and it's a much more serious War than
World War II because if we lose we're
all dead I mean you'll already be dead
so maybe it doesn't concern you as much
but I don't want my children to starve
to death writing me off really early
please don't write me off for 21 years
looks good doesn't it it does
it's a great part of America
it's like an American icon
My Generation it was the Beach Boys yeah
Surfing USA
so
you know tourist Heaven yeah but if I
were a tourist from another planet and I
was like hey let's go visit Earth and
then my travel guy was like well
it's populated by about 10 billion
carnivorous apes and they're armed
markets you see is to see your children
grown educated married and I want to
have great grandchildren that's my goal
okay if you want to have great
grandchildren what you have to do is you
have to help build that environment that
they're going to survive in I want you
to see the facts as they appear to me
I'm a national security guy that's what
I've spent my life working on trying to
protect America
the Constitution the way we live and um
and our futures for our children and
grandchildren
I love my Dad we're both concerned about
security we're both concerned about the
future but there's definitely a
difference in the generational
perspective of this
[Applause]
now I understand his generation because
they grew up right after World War II
the Baby Boomers
they grew up in a world that was
constantly improving
more rights more money the economy
constantly expanded
foreign they saw us go from
fairly primitive industrial society
to what we have today
[Music]
there have been Empires that formed and
collapsed
and about 200 years ago mankind suddenly
discovered how to take energy more
effectively from the Earth
in the start of the Industrial Age
and it was coal and it was
England
and it was a steam engine that could use
that coal and it spread throughout the
whole world we have taken that energy
and built this civilization from it
and the price that's being paid is the
carbonization of the atmosphere and
climate change
[Music]
yeah that's the finale
[Music]
you know and you say in World War II
everybody chipped in and did their part
yeah and that was 75 years ago now we've
been involved in so far
a 19-year war
and in that 19-year war we were told to
go shopping
and to buy more stuff we were never told
to save anything we were never told to
contribute to a war effort they even cut
taxes when we went that's right twice
twice
foreign
[Music]
The House Always Wins and it's a rigged
game it just is
not unlike the banking system and our
political system nowadays
it's all rigged people don't have an
actual choice and a lot of stuff yeah
people have a choice to go to Vegas
when you ran for president I drove all
over New Mexico and other places
all I could think in 2003 was that we
can't actually build an economy off
stripping gambling in crystal meth and
we've made a concerted effort to do that
in this country for the last 20 years
you know a business caters to what
people want
American society has produced enormous
amounts of leisure
they've tried to recreate the feel of
the Roman Empire in the heart of Vegas
and interestingly
it's like late Roman Empire so it's
right as everything collapsed
we have the smarts and the know-how and
the conscience to know that we have to
sustain and protect this Earth because
this is where we live
so we love civilization but we've got to
change the way we're approaching our
economic endeavors
the world is suffering through the worst
financial crisis since the 1930s there's
been a lot of damage done they they hear
700 billion dollar package and they
immediately think the next day
everything is going to be better you're
witnessing so much wealth loss if you
connect the financial system to the
other possible shocks that are out there
you realize it's a we're we're walking
on on Ice Hannah coming through the
phones on the Floor Traders just trying
to rush to get to the point of sale to
get rid of their stock
you know what people built up over years
and years and years
has been erased
at some point
you want to risk that something goes a
foul we were worried about Greek debt
we're worried about Italian debt Spanish
debt I mean it's and so far you know
it's been finessed uh but
uh and you know you can't see what the
U.S treasury is doing behind we're doing
a lot with the US government to keep the
system working and you just don't know
what the limits are so if you think how
can we lead the world in fixing the
economy and fixing the climate you have
to make the Investments now because you
can't wait till you're like Somalia I
mean you may notice Somalia doesn't have
a lot of infrastructure programs that
they fund they're not pushing the
boundaries in technology and that's not
because people in Somalia are stupid
it's not just because they've lived
under Civil War it's because they don't
have Capital they don't have resources
[Music]
okay
capitalism is an economic organization
or it's a way of organizing the economy
that is focused on trying to create
future returns over and above of the
Investments I make today
so it's all about expansion it's all
about making more in the future than we
currently have
when you borrow money well what happens
is the banks would like to charge you
interest not only for the risk but
because they want the the capital to
come back with babies not just to to go
and that's it because they want to make
sure that capital is increasing and
that's how you build wealth and that's
how you increase your assets
and it's that debt that has enabled all
of this to be here it's the accelerant
to economic growth
[Music]
now as long as a company can service
that debt it's okay but Consumer Debt if
it can't be serviced is a problem
Mortgage Debt it can't be serviced as
we've seen is a problem and national
debt if it can't be service can be a
national security threat Alexa how do we
avert a financial crisis
[Music]
here's something I found on Wikipedia
a financial crisis is any of a broad
variety of situations in which some
Financial assets suddenly lose a large
part of their nominal value
preparing for the future
when the future is unknown
is obviously difficult
but we are today taking steps that are
clearly going to make things worse
Finance was really making bets on an
uncertain future
and you want to be careful about making
too many bets especially when there's
some indication that the future might be
very different from the present
so much of our energies caught up in the
financial system that we've neglected
the investment in real things that are
required to take the country forward we
do we have a really come to grips with
this yet because the economic system the
political system just doesn't want to
face it
foreign
has grown but that's indebtedness of
households firms Banks governments the
debts of all these actors in the
economic system have increased much more
than GDP really yeah so
let's say I think maybe in the 1970s or
so the total debts of all these actors
households firms Banks government the
total debt to GDP ratio was maybe of the
order 120 percent
and now that has increased very steadily
over time to about
290 percent so if no one got paid for
three years in continued work exactly
the whole time yeah and didn't eat yeah
yeah or drive cars or anything we could
pay that down yeah yeah but does the
debt matter
well I mean that that matters to some to
to the extent that uh we have a system
it is called capitalism and in that
system we laws are telling us that debts
have to be repaid
how much debt do we need to generate one
dollar of GDP for the economy to create
one extra dollar of income
we need we are relying on 3.3 dollars of
extra debt
and income is basically wages plus
profits that is what GDP is you can also
call it differently you can say it is
value added
created by producing stuff and as a
result of emphasizing on the GDP we have
ended up in a situation where the market
is going on there is some sailing there
is some buying but we really don't know
how well people are doing
you know when we were kids one dollar of
debt pretty much created one dollar of
GDP oh wow so you know it's like
Keynesian economics you put the money
into social projects and it recycles
back into the economy
but today it takes more than three
dollars of debt to produce one dollar of
GDP
and that's all occurred in the last like
30 years wow so in order to create
more money you've got to create more
debt three times as much debt that's
insane more than three times as much
debt it's that access to credit and the
kind of ability to take on lots and lots
of debt that has been able to sustain
this kind of
um Trend in in consumption so there is a
very very strong
relationship between increases in income
and increases in carbon emissions
in the U.S which is already kind of the
most disproportionately high energy
producing High consuming country
per capita spending grew 42 overall from
1990 to 2008. with a 300 increase in
spending on furniture an 80 increase on
clothing and a 15 to 20 increase on
vehicles housing and food despite the
fact that wages were pretty stagnant
over that time period
[Music]
so this is the Wall Street bull which is
a symbol of a positive Market which
means more people are spending money and
spent it the day before our democracies
basically have become dependent on the
idea that there will always be more to
go around that we can expand expand
expand
we know that there's fundamental
uncertainty we just don't know what the
future will hold
[Music]
over the course of my career I've I've
worked in mathematical modeling I was a
space physicist for NASA
and I was on pretty big projects I was
on the Hubble Space Telescope team as a
scientist
I was on Mission to Mars as a space
physicist and so I'd worked on in some
pretty big areas
when people say well how do you know
that the climate models that we have now
will be accurate in 30 years time what I
can tell you is that the models that we
were working on 30 years ago are
actually unbelievably accurate
[Music]
what's happened with the atmosphere is
we're seeing this type of instability
kind of like you know if you if you had
a top just standing there
it'll just fall over and so you're
seeing that type of that type of
wobbling and instability I don't exactly
know
how unstable things are going to be but
to me it's the volatility and the
instability that's even more concerning
than just the pure temperature rise over
time
let's say that inflation were to go over
the top stock market crashes let's say
there are all kinds of sanctions on
exports you can't even export your Tech
you know all you're left with to survive
is you and your environment
you know one of my goals this year was
actually to get more educated on climate
change and
I I took the path that I was going to
see both sides of the argument
of what was interesting to me was I
could find very little
in the climate denier space
the more I read the more I see around me
the more I get concerned
the officials came out and said we're
going to have to release the dams and I
remember looking at my husband and
looking
my daughter and the dog and the house
and thinking am I in the middle of some
movie
so I'm five eight and the water reached
to about right there
until it happens to you you don't you
don't believe that this can happen in
the United States of America
and all of your financial stability is
gone so if we have God forbade any other
emergency that comes up and believe me
that is a source of a traumatic kind of
panic that sets in when we go oh
you know what if something happens what
if there's another emergency that that
arises then we have no funds
never did I ever imagine that everything
that I would work so hard for would be
taken from me in in a matter of hours
and so I do believe that climate change
is going to have a huge economic impact
and what wealth you have can be
eradicated
in in a matter of hours
[Music]
we had a house up here on the hill that
my wife wanted to get out of because it
was dangerous for the fires you know the
climate change everything's getting
crispy we better get to somewhere where
we're not going to get burned up yeah so
we moved to this beautiful place
and the fire didn't get us
but the debris flow after the fire wiped
us out man we had like mud four feet
here
you were here right oh we were how did
you get out rescued by helicopters
you know I said my wife we you got a
sheet
and she said yeah I said what are you
gonna do with the sheets I'm going to
write uh help out there you know she
said maybe make it SOS I said that's a
good idea went out there Drew SOS with
the in the mud and pretty soon
they come they let a guy down
and they said we weren't sure if it was
SOS or an area code it looked like it
could have been 805 and I said well I
got to work on my Essence man but we
were lucky you know we could afford to
well people died people died in this
right yeah oh terrible people were
washed washed right through our place uh
and we were the lucky ones you know we
had the money
to refurbish this place but you know
imagine
people's you know struggling all over
the world with this climate yeah well
that's the way it starts it's it's you
read about it and it seems far away but
then something happens and paying it's
right on you it gets very personal
oh my gosh
words can't describe it
words can't describe it
Global Systems of Finance are deeply
connected and based on on Housing
Finance in places like the United States
so if you get in a situation where a
homeowner
can't can't pay an insurance premium
can't hold on to their mortgage for that
reason
um defaults on a mortgage goes into
foreclosure you have kind of you're
setting in motion the sort of early
parts of the story that we know is a
very familiar one from 2007 and 2008.
and we're not particularly good at
preparing for difficult times way in the
future when in fact we've got difficult
choices right now when you survey people
in the U.S and in the UK about sources
of stress it's work and money
[Music]
Alexa how do I solve our economic
problems
sorry I don't know that
we're heading off the cliff in terms of
climate change there's a real urgency on
this now that cannot be denied I uh I
grew up in the heart of the military
industrial complex my father became a
general after I went off to college I
went to the Foreign Service school at
Georgetown Madeline Albright was one of
my advisors in college and I thought I
know how the world works there are
people in charge and some with a plan
there's someone running stuff when my
father was head of NATO and I got to go
over there and visit and hear the kind
of questions that senators and
congressmen were coming up with I
realized whoa no one's running anything
and the mistake that the great majority
of us make is that there are groups of
people running things someone has a
master plan there's a cabal or a
conspiracy behind it all that's
running it and it's just not the case
there was how's the conference hey good
good
no I think
well I think they I think they really
wanted to hear what's going on and what
the challenges are yeah and that's what
I gave them
kind of reading this thing about
Venezuela you see what happens when an
economy collapses total collapse I mean
is it was it just initially the oil
prices or they've tried to make it a
populist democracy you know where now
Maduro is is a dictator but you know
supposedly people like him but in that
actual fact Cuba's in there and um I was
down about six months ago in Colombia
and they were telling me that actually
the Cubans are going up to the
Venezuelan Army and they're disarming
them because they don't trust the this
is the way you take over a country you
get rid of you know you put your
security forces in then you build up
your extra military force and then you
go to the military that might be loyal
to the country and say uh give us your
weapons
so a lot of Venezuelan militaries become
refugees oh wow they were disarmed and
sent out of the country yeah and there's
millions of people that are just there
they lived there they were born there
and they're struggling to survive
it's uh I mean we're heading in that
direction already before we've even had
the economic breakdown
with armed groups in the streets you had
20 000 armed people in the streets
yesterday well I was just a
demonstration
brought guns
you don't bring guns to a demonstration
unless you're demonstrating you'd like
to kill people that don't agree with you
Venezuela can be an example of what
happens when Civil Society breaks down
because you don't have stable
transparent rule of law government and
you don't invest in your infrastructure
the right way in many ways Venezuela is
a leading indicator of the challenges
that will face the whole world
many like Erin Burgos feel they have no
choice
is now its most chaotic and dangerous
but that's what happens in these
countries but by these countries you
mean countries that have incompetent
leadership
countries that that have uh that are
failing to take care of their people but
that compensate for that by setting up
repressive mechanisms to ensure that
they stay in power I just worry about it
happening in the United States
you have a country like Venezuela where
the first thing that collapsed is their
energy infrastructure and then now we're
finding out that it's not just
electrical and oil pumping now their
water infrastructure is collapsing and
this is a country that's tropical that's
filled with water
the energy sector has not received the
training or investment of needs and the
experts were kicked out and so the
energy sector particular the oil sector
is collapsing and that was a major
source of revenue for the country at the
same time you have significant drought
in a country that has a lot of water
which means the dams cannot produce the
same electricity as they used to so you
have collapse of the electrical sector
along with the oil sector along with
civil society and this means you also
have collapsing water infrastructure
because even if you have the pipes if
you don't have electricity you can't
operate everything so severe strain
which means food shortages riots a lack
of money this is a major problem
United States and Europe is Rich but if
we choose to under invest in our
infrastructure and if we choose to not
prepare for the future we could suffer
these kind of consequences as well the
impact of climate change is not a
straight-line function it's clearly
a a progression that is accelerating in
magnitude very dramatically and so any
lapse at this point in responding is
going to have I think a critical uh
impact down the road much sooner than we
would anticipate this is a crisis
waiting to happen it's a slow-moving
crisis in front of our eyes
so when you see in a movie an asteroid
is going to hit us in six months but Mr
President we've been working on this
potential problem for six years
in real life the asteroid takes
everybody out the same goes for climate
change the same goes for a whole host of
issues we have because when people see
something on TV and look politics is a
confidence game and people look at the
politician they go he must know what
he's talking about or she must know what
she's talking about that doesn't mean
there's an actual plan with any kind of
consistent Machinery behind it to
produce results
as the waters start to recede the
financial costs will add up
are you tired of living in a home like
this when you really want to be living
in a home like this
let's check it out
we've got tons of waterfront property
and more coming every day Century 22 now
serving parts of California
[Music]
for those of you that went to the
mountain and enjoyed that 16 feet of
brand new fresh powder nice job but as
you can see we've got a hot front coming
in so tomorrow there's going to be 155
degrees Fahrenheit so you might want to
break out those Speedos
you read you read the big article about
Peter Thiel who's the guy who's made the
big Fortune off Tech has bought and
built bunkers in New Zealand right
because their plan is we're all going to
die and then they're going to ride it
out somehow even though they won't but
there's the belief that their money will
insulate and shelter them from what's
coming I've always been people who
predicted Doomsday
I mean I've heard you know I've heard
climate change liken to a World War
you know the difference is that we know
a lot more about what's coming come on
down to our luxury survival condo and
don't let the armor get and get you down
so unless you can produce thousands of
years worth of Water and Air in food in
your underground bunker you're not going
to make it and the most likely outcome
will be that the construction workers
probably non-union that you paid to
build this Parker for you know exactly
where it is and they have access to all
the tools to dig you out of it like a
truffle
the sooner people start using their
money as a tool instead of a goal in
life the faster we're going to be able
to dig ourselves out of this hole okay
so Dad we've I know you don't want to
pay attention and you don't want to be I
do filmed with Miniatures because it
could
you know you don't want to look like the
guy in Dr Strangelove or any other
retired General playing exactly what it
looks like
look we we need to set up something that
people can understand how it works we
have
like a grocer farmer another store here
A Bank a homeowner and then emergency
services and over here is like nature or
we'll even say foreign country or Africa
or somewhere else so
but the first thing I got to do is
change how everything's set up because
we need the bank
in between
the country club and everybody else
we have a huge financial system compared
to what the what I could call the real
economy that is where people work and
produce and and and live
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what we were talking about was trying to
explain Capital structures and insurance
and financing and mortgages using
Children's Choice so we have money I
don't know if it's gonna work
first thing is
the grocery store is a business and it
makes money and they deposit the money
in the bank okay
boom okay
John worked at the grocery store and he
gets paid by the grocery store and he
decides he wants to buy a house okay he
doesn't have enough money
from his earnings to buy the house but
he goes to the bank and the bank said oh
we'll give you the money
to buy the house
and in return you'll give us an IOU
we have to look at the house is it uh is
it does it pass inspection yeah pass
inspection and uh and uh can you afford
it based on your monthly income well
um
say yes yes okay good so here's a
mortgage okay so here's the money and um
and by the way this is just like a real
bank because in the real Bank they're
not sure can this guy pay for it just
tell them yes tell them yes come on
we typically think that bank takes
deposits from us and then lends it out
the balance sheet it creates one entry
on this side another entry on that side
it has sort of claims to come back and
if it really comes back as expected they
make a return on that and it's basically
making money on everything we are
in the old days I would put this
mortgage and I would say this is an
asset for me because you're going to pay
me every month to pay this mortgage
right so you're telling all your buddies
you better way to make money okay so the
bank takes the IOU
and the bank sells the IOU to into the
What's called the secondary Market okay
and it gets a fee for that
and once I have this mortgage and maybe
the mortgage for many other houses in
the neighborhood and ideally from other
neighborhoods as well I throw this into
us what we call a special purpose
vehicle which really in legal terms is
typically a trust or a corporation these
asset shielding devices
and then you issue claims against these
new legal shells to investors
they package these ious
uh
so there's many of them and they sell
them to people like insurance companies
or
foreign Banks and they can be leveraged
which means I can make loans off these
things which are lost you have leverage
here so you can make more loans so the
system always generates cash
they can reduce their risk because
they're not just buying a mortgage
they're buying a package of mortgages in
some cases they're just buying a slice
of the interest rate off a package of
mortgages
and so all of these are called
derivatives and everything works as long
as there's an expectation that the loan
will be repaid that John will at the
right time each month
give the bank money to pay down his
share of the IOU
foreign
way the banking system worked it used to
work that the banker would look you in
the eye and say are you credit worthy
can I trust you
the banks really aren't keeping the
mortgages on their books anymore they're
selling those mortgages so that they can
be repackaged as other kinds of
financial instruments so they're able to
sort of pass the buck pass the risk off
to the next person
depending on how they're rated by the
rating agencies these are reputable
investment opportunities for retirement
funds General yeah patient funds sure
put them in here so the investors are
buying an interest in the cash flow that
comes from the homeowners into the pool
that we've created but have sort of a
claim against this house as well because
this cash flow is backed by the mortgage
against the home so something as
illiquid as formidable as this building
in the land it stands on we can become a
globally tradable financial asset
through appropriate legal coding
[Music]
this is your loan it travels through
this system
the bank has the loan sells it it
becomes a security it becomes part of
the balance sheet of money market mutual
funds these money market mutual funds
then basically exchange this your loan
the your collateral your house in a
collateralized cash deal and the whole
purpose of both the cash and the
collateralized cash deal is that it
allows the various actors to operate in
derivative markets and make very high
rates of short-term return
foreign
[Music]
globally right so we made a huge jump
from let's say the 12th century when the
first assignable notes came about two
treating that as an asset that we can
just trade on a global global market
[Music]
the bottom there is tangible value
the same value is used not just one time
but two or three or four times in fact
interest financial sector Trading
it is not going to product for
productive investment in firms it is
also not going to finance and fund uh
climate change mitigation and
decarbonization money creates more money
well creates more wealth and this is a
circle and it just goes off
at the end of the day it's our houses
which are the value of our houses which
are backing this up
the IMF has called it the shadow banking
system
a shadow here doesn't mean that it is
illegal it also doesn't mean that it is
necessarily shady and so on it is just
that it is Shadow because there are no
rules there is it's it's hardly any
rules it's sort of
almost the wild west of the of the
financial sector
[Music]
and uh the problem with the derivative
Market is there is no market so it's
like one and one swaps between Bankers
it's like you and I say hey uh an old
Bank you're working for and uh so I've
got some bonds and uh I want you to
insure them for me in case the interest
rate changes would you insure these
bonds for me how much would you charge
tell me your prices that's a good deal
I'll get a bonus for setting up the
insurance you'll get a bonus for you
know taking in the money to do these but
I work at a different bank it's a good
deal you just bought those and I figure
I could also get those because I know a
guy in Saudi Arabia or China that would
pay two cents more and I could make 50
Grand off lined up so far
it's like the old Insurance principles
how many people can Insure One person's
house you know can the whole each person
in the neighborhood put a hundred
thousand dollar policy on that house and
each person collect a hundred thousand
dollars from the hundred thousand dollar
house burns down
foreign As Americans we're short-sighted
we don't think long term and financial
literacy was not this complicated 100
years ago he had a little bit of money
he probably didn't have a bank account
you paid your bills and you passed bills
around and you kept it under the
mattress you already kept on the match
sober mindset the critical derivatives
for our financial markets today are
actually um or the ones that brought
down the financial system in 2008 where
the credit default swaps
um and the collateralize debt
obligations and the credit default swap
is basically a kind of an insurance
contract
um which basically says if some Assets
in the markets decline in value the
insurer has to pay me a fee
and the beauty of the CDs Gravity Falls
swap was that you didn't have to hold
the asset yourself
it's like me taking out a fire insurance
on my neighbor's house
and if that house burns down I get the
premium the value of these Financial
transactions is much much larger than
the tangible real Capital which is
basically the houses of the families the
households the notional value of the
derivatives Market is 600 trillion
dollars and that is about let's say
eight to ten times as large as Global
GDP foreign
[Music]
City with how many trillions of dollars
of real estate value right there at
least hundreds of billions it will no
longer be there like how does that work
how does that work in the banking sector
how does that work in the insurance
Market the reinsurance market
what's been collateralized off that real
estate this is not just different actors
exchanging in different markets or in
different uh legal transactions our
financial system is such that we have
huge Banks Mega Banks too big to fail
Banks very often operate operating both
sides of the same Market
the big Banks they don't necessarily
know how much
risk their counterparty Bank in some
other country is willing to undertake
nobody really understands the legal
interdependencies that are built onto
these contracts and that can ultimately
bring down the entire Financial system
the system is so complicated that the
accountability is lost so the real value
is actually here
these are all the transactions which are
built on top of the real economy
foreign
[Music]
then there's Doherty
um the small town of Doherty is not not
a whole lot there today
[Music]
just it was a town that once had a
general store when I was growing up had
the church
that you know had a post office but you
know not anymore
[Music]
agriculture in Rural America has gotten
a preview of the automation that's about
to hit the rest of the country in the
next 10 years
we're here at the Town Square in Dewitt
Arkansas and if you look around I mean
there's not a
ton of bustling businesses here but one
of the busiest businesses is Department
of Human Services
so when we Define the real economy let's
not forget Farms
88 percent are still small Family Farms
so this is a grain storage bin on my
parents Family Farm
[Music]
thank you
this is my my dad's place
he's going to be 87 mom's 85. they've
lived here since 1956.
so
a lot of years
well we are a team yeah
[Music]
how many times you have to have intense
rains heat Spells freezings at the wrong
point to get the crops to not come in
once
we do protect our Farmers we give them
crop insurance and the crop insurance is
subsidize we have Agricultural Extension
services and they pay for that but they
probably don't pay the full cost of that
it's a free market economy but it's also
a national security issue
Federal crop insurance program list
started as a response to the effects of
the Dust Bowl and the Great Depression
many many areas throughout the United
States were were severely affected by
the Dust Bowl many farmers lost
everything in addition to most of
America being devastated by the
Depression Farmers acutely suffered
during that time
[Music]
many parts of the Plains were just
completely filled with dust many crops
were lost
due to the weather the extreme weather
due to insects
[Music]
but it's the large scale like my dad
said the large-scale events that
everybody kind of worries about like a
big drought
[Music]
I think that our aquifer
in some places is is down to like 20
percent and in a lot of places at 50 and
then we're actually using more water
than
we have at any other time
we have our pumping plants in and we've
we're building on canals and this was
this is actually the first phase we're
trying to get water to this this Indian
bile and then and then we're going to
use that for the main
water supply
in Arkansas we're going to have a
drought event every growing season
it doesn't matter if if we just came
like this last flood that we had here as
soon as we came out of that flood event
we were irrigating because it was our
soil
is uh
it's not real deep we have what they
call a hard pan underneath it pretty
close to the surface which helps with
the rice growing yes very helpful
it just gets more expensive every day we
thought we were going to have a lot of
infrastructure money maybe to come about
but but it's it hasn't come about and
it's in its Federal infrastructure money
well the way that was originally set up
was that the federal government was
gonna was going to
be responsible for 65 percent the state
10 in our local District 25. and there's
a lot of people benefit from this other
than just the farmers but that's who's
got to pay for it is they're going to be
the ones that's actually using the water
and I'm assuming we'll have to do a
whole bunch of stuff like that as
temperature rises and and
bring patterns change then when every
person we've talked to about farming and
different methods of farming whether
it's till or no-till or
the organic or not
each piece of land is different
in each little Community is different
and the ecosystem there is different so
how can a giant
JP Morgan how can they service a
community like this well and and why
would they want to yeah that's the rest
of the story I mean that's not going to
be a profit Center for them to come out
here and look at a man that's that's
farming two thousand three thousand
acres they're looking for
20 50 000 Acre Farms to where they can
justify spending some time on them the
relationships with the banks they've
gotten big too but it used to be these
smaller Banks and uh
and they knew your dad and his dad and
hey if you went to a farm sale and hey I
like this tractor and it was 27 20
000 you just called the bank it says hey
I need it okay it's in your account
60 years ago if you made a crop you made
money
period if you made a crop
you paid all your bills and you could
send your kids to school and you you buy
your groceries you were you were okay
today you can make a crop and lose your
assets
foreign
I mean if you were 30 years ago when we
did this we get all combine was was
35
000
and now combine is you know four hundred
thousand dollars
when you're looking at machines that you
it's about a time you have your your
headers and your everything to go with
it being upward or close to a half a
million dollars
um
where else is someone else buying half a
million dollar equipment and uh barely
making ends meet
every year
and agricultural
cost or just to be a farmer and even a
small farmer are almost cost prohibitive
unless your family has been in farming
for Generations thank God Almighty for
for such a good looking crop
While others have have had to struggle
oh here's some fellas yes they were
riding with
y'all will be riding around
I'll just meet you back up to the fuel
tank all right thanks Zach see you there
okay
Farms are similar to owning a house
you've got to clean the gutters you've
got a you know sweep the sidewalk
um and the same thing with a farm you've
got
certain maintenances that have to be
done on an annual basis to keep it in a
working order
before automation
everything in here is hand written
24th 1955. yep and every day and that's
everything that happened during that day
all the money that came in they made
four loans like this is these are the
loans that we made that day and you see
the size of the loans 150 dollars five
hundred dollars
the countryside Across America not just
in our rural community but other rural
communities used to have a lot of
small community banks that were very
plugged into their
communities and to the people that live
there and trying to help them grow their
businesses and their lives
so just afraid of what the landscape
holds going forward
you're just a number your your q-sip
number on a bond security and here's
where you mail your check now it's
getting harder and harder for those
Farmers to to stay in business because
they cannot get the funding because with
each year of them incurring loss and and
then no hope of
that the prices don't get better the
next year regardless of the type of
natural disasters and things that happen
and so the farmer gets further and
further behind and we've had several
Farmers that are actually going out of
business they're having to sell their
equipment and and turn the farm over to
someone else to farm
foreign
it's actually something that I have no
control over and none of us around in
England Arkansas have any control over
and uh
at uh
at our at the last one like in 2008 when
they were saying that the banks wouldn't
have money to loan to your farmers and
and I had several Farmers that were just
pulling their hair out they were just
are you going to be able to blow me
enough money to finish this crop and I
finally told him just go home and watch
Andy Griffith
and quit watching CNN and fox and said
you know this this as far as I know
we're going to have the money and we're
going to take care of you and that
and and you need to quit watching
all of those
those uh
stuff to scare you yeah that you have no
control over so
and I mean a couple of weeks later he
came back and said you know that's the
best advice I've gotten so far this year
the rainfall amounts we don't get an
inch anymore it's either three inches or
nothing you know because everything is
is extremes
foreign
[Music]
many of those restrictions on banks are
being peeled back so we still have
trading and derivatives it's uh not uh
we don't know what it is there's
hundreds of trillions of dollars
maybe 600 maybe 800 trillions of dollars
of of derivatives on currency exchanges
that can't be covered
it's like after 1980s oh Gordon Gekko is
a great guy he taught us greed is good
look what it's gotten that's a cycle in
America you have to create wealth you
can't create wealth by just taking it
from other people through taxes people
have to be incentivized to create wealth
and this has been great but this has
been the great the great virtues of
Western democracy for three but it's
also been the massively misunderstood is
so go back to the post-civil war United
States and the growth the growth was
made off land that people were literally
killed and chased off of and they're
like hey man look at all this free land
thank you
and that's how money was made
[Music]
you have to resolve that we can do
better going forward
American capitalism can be pretty
heartless
if you look back at the American Civil
War and what happened right afterwards
we industrialized America we went into
the Gilded Age people looked at these
robber barons and said this can't last
and we ended up in the Progressive
Movement
this is the age of Reagan the Reagan Era
was the relaxation of the administrative
state it was the sort of you know let
let big firms get bigger it's let's make
money let's do it all with money let's
let Charities take care of people forget
about government programs and that's run
really since Reagan was elected
thank you very much
I was raised rad
I was raised in a red family
I grew up in the 80s
foreign
love with Ronald Reagan
I idolized Reagan I saw Reagan and I
said
I want his job in fact my parents told
me I mailed him a dollar bill by the
face dollar bill with my picture on it
the maxim is dovayai no proviai trust
but verify
you repeat that at every meeting
hahaha but I I wanted to be in politics
I wanted to be the first woman president
United States I thought it was
fascinating we can leave our children
with an unrepayable massive debt and a
shattered economy
where we can leave them Liberty in a
land where every individual has the
opportunity to be whatever God intended
us to be
you know people like to say economics is
a science but it really follows politics
change came out and and looked at it he
saw the political need that's how we
understood macroeconomics Friedman came
out and looked at it and he saw deficit
spending and he saw government control
and he saw high taxes he said there has
to be a better way he reinvented
classical economics they called it
neoliberal economics quoted Milton
Friedman had said that that our the
economy
of the United States ought to be judged
by the number of imports that we have
and not exports and I thought maybe this
was a typo or something
and so I asked him I said I mean are you
for real trickle-down economic starts in
1980 it's right around there late 70s we
get into it but the bottom line is has
two parts to it first fire the cops not
the cops on Main Street the cops on Wall
Street turn them loose let those Banks
do whatever they want to do and so here
we are now 40 years into the age of
Reagan and people are looking at what
it's done okay it's made a lot of people
really wealthy it's made we won the Cold
War during that period not necessarily
because of that but we won the Cold War
and uh America became the sort of
supreme power
but for the people of America it hasn't
been so good but I know the real wages
went down real wages went down people in
this country look back at they want to
make America as great as it was in the
1950s that's when the marginal tax rate
was 91 percent I know
Ronald Reagan would my mother loved him
she watched him every Sunday night on GE
theater at the end he would say
at General Electric progress is our most
important product
what would Ronald Reagan say if you told
him that GE spends more money on stock
BuyBacks than it does on R D in 1950
stock BuyBacks were illegal they were
considered Market manipulation
now investment analysts look at that
company say what companies are really
smart I think their Stock's going to
continue to grow up because they've got
a really great stock buyback program
it does nothing for the economy
the average American is they're living
in the GDP of 1980. yeah I mean yeah
clearly the world has changed but and
the Commodities you can buy are not the
same Commodities but in terms of your
let's say average to the extent that we
can measure living standards living
standards have not improved
firms Finance their investment out of
their profits that's what people think
now if you look at the 500 biggest U.S
corporations 50 of the profits are paid
as dividends 50 of the profits are used
for buying back stocks all the profits
dissipate are gone so how do they
finance their investment if they if they
that
the president
's big surprise about the collapse on
the markets yesterday is still enduring
popularity as much to the economic boom
that America has enjoyed under his
leadership
more people are working than ever before
in history
there are productivity is up so is our
manufacturing product up
there is no runaway inflation as there
has been in the past so uh it's like hey
I don't think anyone's good panic
because the all the economic indicators
are solid
but the warning signs have long been
there in the closed factories in many
American small towns I mean there is
this notion of billionaires creating
employment and that is trickle-down
economics
uh the problem about that is that in
history it has never happened there is
no such thing as tackle down economics
it simply doesn't exist it's it really
is voodoo economics
when you put the smartest people in the
world in finance which is what we've
done for the last 25 years in this
country
you can't hold back their imagination
and their creativity
the speed and scale of global economic
change has overwhelmed the national
systems of rules and regulations so our
first test is to agree tougher and most
transparent supervision of banks hedge
funds and what is known as the global
Shadow banking system
and so when you get right down to it I'm
a licensed banker and so when The
Regulators come to my bank we're a very
simple little bank they look for the
Sops they look for due diligence on on
projects we've done it's pretty easy
you go to a big bank Wells or JP Morgan
or Goldman and you're a regularly like
what is this I see these emails and I
mean yeah they don't understand it
because they're not working in it they
didn't invent it sure it's like trying
to teach people a theory of quantum
gravity when they've had a high school
Physics course and they're inspecting
Stephen Hawking or something
the Earth is a bounded natural system
that can't expand forever the beauty of
the legal code and derivatives are a
product of the legal good is that we can
expand it how far we want right so we
always create new types of assets we
create new types of legal tricks um in
the end and the two systems are not
easily compatible
[Music]
if you're very rich and you gamble with
your money and you lose it in Las Vegas
that is what you want and it's your it's
your problem but here if they lose their
money here
it is our problem
the market can't punish for things it
doesn't know anything about and they
haven't factored any of the risks that
all this could change natural disaster
could have major repercussions for our
financial system just because they will
have an effect on the asset
[Music]
asset rural Reserve Banks to issue
additional currency on good assets and
thus the banks that reopen will be able
to meet every legitimate call
it is sound currency because it is
backed by actual good assets
[Music]
and so what happens is that there's an
event
and then when the event happens and
everybody wakes up and suddenly there's
what we call in the financial system
contagion and people unload they unload
stocks they try to get their derivatives
repaid they want their insurance
policies cached and the market starts to
unravel
when the market starts to go down the
plugs get pulled everywhere
and so what you're dealing with in in
climate change is not only the direct
impact but also the possibility of
contagion economic contagion economic
Financial
those views are merely forecasts and as
always we'll evolve with the arrival of
new information
we actually have made it clear that we
will bail out these Financial actors we
will build them this cannot be sustained
if it runs only because the central
banks go in and buy assets right
recently it was proposed that the
European Central Bank should start
buying shares of companies so not only
that but shares so we're effectively
socializing the obligation to create
Financial returns for the holders of
capital assets and that can't go on
forever
[Music]
even though every politician says this
is the most important election in your
lifetime
these forces aren't tamed or Unleashed
by a single election
[Applause]
in the news in the last couple weeks
we've read about the coronavirus yeah
and dude China's acting like this is
like zombie apocalypse I'm actually kind
of afraid of that career I don't want to
get on a plane yeah do we have a
government that's competent enough and
organized enough to handle that kind of
response no man I mean we can't even
handle like homelessness in the city of
L.A you know what I mean like we can't
even figure out how to properly fund
anything let alone a pandemic
foreign
s live under the illusion that they're
incredibly different from other people
when I was in college everything started
to to melt down on the Balkans
everyone's like these people are savages
they've been fighting each other for
hundreds of years it's like they just
came down out of the trees or something
then you're there and and you realize
these people live in houses that have
electricity and two-car garages and
refrigerators and not only children in
college but several Generations that
have gone through college and they all
spoke the same language
and these people killed each other they
committed genocide 250 000 killed rape
camps concentration camps ethnic
cleansing
this was a plan to ethnically cleanse
Kosovo and get rid of the Albanian
population are we going to stand for
that is France going to stand for that I
don't think so
like many countries as a system starts
to break down the in their case it was
the Communist system and in our case our
capitalist system is starting to break
down and people turn on each other
because some leaders think
everybody's upset right now and I can
motivate my group to take stuff from
another group Europe has not seen
displaced people in these numbers since
the Second World War
and those are the kinds of things we
have to worry about with climate change
because it happens when resources start
to get tight and everybody's a human
everybody's prone to these things we've
pre-cut boards that we could put over
the windows in the event that there are
looters and things like that to protect
the house
the U.N said just two weeks ago a
billion within 30 years okay a billion
displaced people a billion refugees
because they can't grow their food the
way they used to because of the drought
or because of floods or because of
collapse of systems how much worse is
this going to get before it gets better
I think the general view is this is
going to continue deteriorating
for the time being it's a the next rains
are a long while off for the world this
is a very bad thing because it's
billions of people dislocated massive
economic consequences
can you
a society that's been as successful as
this one has in a material sense and can
it transform itself you know in the past
Empires haven't been able to do that
what would these Romans say
could they help us
unlikely unlikely
[Music]
the heritage of America is Roman you
know the men who wrote their
constitution had studied the history of
Rome
I mean the Senate is it's Roman and it's
failing us just like the Roman senate
failed you know there was a Greek
philosopher who said that that
governments go through Cycles
they go from uh democracy to oligopoly
to uh to to dictatorships and they
collapsed you know I'm talking about
Aristotle but
I mean actually there was an aerosol I
was a different guy no it was Aristotle
no it was a maybe it was polybius I
forget it I um I'll bet you cash it's
Aristotle because we're in Vegas I will
bet you cash it's aerosol because
Aristotle Aristotle came up with the
definitions of the three kinds of
governments and their alter egos
so you have a democracy which when it
goes bad becomes a mobocracy
you have a monarchy which when it goes
bad becomes a tyranny and you have an
aristocracy which when it goes bad
becomes an oligopoly
he's building on the work of a
predecessor what's the name of the
predecessor we have to find that out I
don't know you tell me we'll find it I
don't know I have to look it up well was
attained largely through trade
into the warehouses float goods from all
over the Empire and Beyond
it was the wealthy fume rather than the
many who benefited from the riches and
vast resources of the empire
this imbalance and the irresponsible
behavior of public officials would
become major reasons for Rome's eventual
decline
okay so Dad and I had this bet and I
need you to see if I'm right or he's
right okay
it's about Aristotle oh boy I know so
you know I I was like well Aristotle
describe you know the death of democracy
and what happens to different forms of
government as they decay
foreign
[Music]
foreign
Empire was mainly a huge gigantic
enormous humongous
Financial collapse at some point the
Emperors had just ran out of money
there are lots of different theories why
the Roman Empire did collapse I think
what we know now is that there has been
a long economic decline before the Roman
Empire collapsed before the German
hordes came down and in Concord
um Italy and conquered Rome ultimately
right so the question is what triggered
the long economic decline disparity
between the rich and the poorest
they yes you speak in Latin now yeah
yeah Latin
massive amounts of inequality may not be
politically sustainable
governments fund themselves through
either debt or through taxation in Rome
you would basically go and and try to
squeeze more returns out of your
provinces that you occupied or you might
launch Another War to get the returns to
feed Rome and feed those who were
running the system overall
and I think that's that's the common
denominator because we live in a quite
different system today right so today
it's our essential bank so doing the
rescue operation one thing about the
financial markets one of the real power
is if they can pull forward action from
the future to the present if there's
credible policy after all most of what
central banks do is effectively that
so big trees fall hard the market can
adapt to anything as long as there's
Clarity transparency and honesty and I
don't think we're getting that
there were a lot of things that caused
the problem but I mean
essentially
the structure of Rome held together for
a good long time until finally it just
ran out of economic wherewithal and
Leadership politicians were bought what
the founders of our Republic warned us
about over and over that if you get
really wealthy and you lose your moral
character it's over well that's where we
are because we are very close to a
moment in which we could start
slowly going down and if you're not very
careful we will go down faster and
faster and faster and faster
roller coaster it will be a lot of fun
maybe
you know the ancient malediction
may you live in interesting times
[Music]
so
that's how it ended last time
except this time it won't just be
barbarians it'll be the planet itself
that's on fire
they're still actify in that area
monitor the conditions and know what
you'll do if the fire threatens
in the Smoky aftermath of the worst
start to Fire season anyone can remember
while some search for Solutions others
want someone to blame
if I should take a break and let it
settle in you know take an intermission
Financial Ingenuity has been part of
this system since the Dutch invented the
okay
but a lot of it isn't Finance of London
but Dad listen people get pretty
everybody thought Bernie Madoff was a
genius yeah foreign investors looked at
the United States and said you know the
United States their best that's the
safest place in the world I can put my
money
I mean we've had five six biblical like
events we're continuing to have them so
I I need to to question the validity of
the value of and viability of my land
long term
[Music]
a little over seven years ago Hurricane
Sandy blew through here causing tens of
billions of dollars in property damage
and since then
New York has built more bigger taller
and more expensive because we the people
are on the hook
for the cost of the insurance if another
hurricane comes and hits New York City
National flood insurance program is a
federally run public program of
insurance it's run by the Federal
Emergency Management agency
it provides flood insurance for
virtually all homeowners and small
businesses in the country so this is
pretty unusual actually a lot most other
countries have private markets for flood
insurance but the US does not
it's a supplementary policy that is
subsidized by the government and so all
citizens are to some extent footing the
bill for Coastal property owners
in order to build a huge condominium
development in a floodplain in New York
City you of course need a lot of capital
Municipal actors in New York City are
very interested in continuing to promote
a version of New York City in which
as much of the available land remains
viable for continued Economic
Development because property taxes are
so important there as as elsewhere
well the original program of the
national flood insurance program was
supposed to stop Construction in very
high risk areas areas where water moves
with velocity particularly floodways
along the river where water moves the
same rate of the as the river hurricanes
zone areas where the where the storm
surge comes in the the building is it's
almost impossible to build a really safe
building against a 14-foot wall of water
coming in at you in a storm surge
there's a lot of vested interests that
don't care construction industry for
example they'd like to build a house on
a beach while the tide is out as long as
they can sell it before the tide comes
back in
and and once they've sold it of course
the risk is now somebody else's
the ways in which financial actors
securitized mortgages in
the run-up to the last financial crisis
is still going on so the building
contractors all want to minimize the
flood program the town wants to minimize
it want to hold down the elevations on
the maps and and fight every map that
comes out by the national flood
insurance program that causes problems
delay in implementation uh maybe never
implementation
the coastal communities are on some of
the most valuable land and the country
and as a consequence people are going to
fight to protect uh their investment
position
I thought okay the city's not requiring
me to have flood insurance
my realtor didn't tell me I had to have
flood insurance you know honestly you
don't look at the flood maps when you
move into a neighborhood you just you
fall in love with the house
and 85 percent of the people in my
neighborhood were not insured shelter
the United States is uniquely vulnerable
to building into disaster likely
physically vulnerable areas because of
our Reliance on local rule particularly
for zoning decisions that's part of our
Bedrock of the United States
rights and local rights and it's
actually has a lot of advantages
but has a major disadvantage which is
that local governments depend on
revenues that are coming from their
buildings from their residents who are
building and living in their localities
and that means that all residents
benefit from development
the politics of provision are so tied up
with land values in the United States
that if property values go down then the
tax assessments adjust to reflect that
and you're bringing in less revenue for
the tax base which means less investment
in local amenities in schools and local
public transportation
in Texas we don't have
state income tax
it's another reason why you want to live
here because it's cheap but people are
taxed on their land
the maps that are in existence for where
a 100 or 500 year flood will happen are
so outdated and no longer accurate
the risk and the cost of that risk even
within the insurance industry is not as
accurate as it needs to be in order for
us to appreciate what the cost of
climate is
Insurance actors have found ways to kind
of take an insurance policy and
securitize that and transfer it to kind
of capital risk markets so they're not
really holding the bag
which means that they're willing to kind
of underwrite more and more property
which means that people can kind of
continue to build in Risky areas
I don't think anyone would want to come
in and and look at the house and come
through salt water and want to buy it
this is my Nest Egg yeah this is how I'm
going to help my kids and my retirement
but now because you bought it in an area
where there's rising sea level
maybe that nest egg is not so secure and
in order to convert his nest egg to cash
he's got to be able to sell the house
yeah but now nobody will ensure the next
30-year mortgage what happens to John
John's lost his retirement nestec okay
so John is now literally John on the
street
the the nice the nice the nice house
that we're gonna buy on in Florida to
retire
this was their house in Florida they
were going to move to Alabama okay well
they're not moving they may still move
to Alabama they may be living in a
trailer park
flood involves the US government in this
really peculiar way fire is privately
underwritten so it's private insurers
and
what's happening with fire risk is that
some primary insurers are going out of
business you know in events like the
California wildfires that can put an
insurer out of business if they have
outstanding liabilities that you know
exceed what they can pay off
then we started talking and you told me
about buying a house in Sausalito yeah
so what happened so we called insurance
company two days before two or three
days before and let them know we're
getting close in a few days and they
call us back say hey we can't insure
that house they're like what you're like
yeah it's it's on a list of
neighborhoods that we don't insure
anymore so these entire neighborhood's
gonna be uninsured and they also told us
they don't know if they're going to
reinsure
the current owner of the house either
that's an entire that's you know
billions of dollars of houses across the
state that is going to have an insurance
problem
[Music]
the insurance companies are insuring for
one year
so as things get worse the insurance
companies are definitely not going to be
able to come to the rescue of these
homeowners
latent hidden climate risks that might
exist in different places in different
housing markets should they burst could
could take down the entire Financial
system
and right now this house is listed for
forty nine thousand dollars at the peak
of the market it went to about two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
it's not only the owners that lose their
assets it's a financial intermediaries
that lose their clients against them
it's those that bought the securitized
mortgages and other assets that are
linked to them just as we have seen in
the 2008 crisis and unless we're
prepared to continue to write the same
check over and over again we need to
start to scrutinize
are we hardening the utilities and the
infrastructure around these homes
sufficiently so they can weather these
storms going forward or should we in
fact not permit the investment of
capital that is going to be subject to
uh climate change conditions in a
negative way and we need to think about
that no that's that's that's the really
scary thing because we're not
you know we're not hardening any of our
infrastructure
I mean not yet it's very expensive guys
thinking about it but nobody's done it
yet
well from an oil company standpoint
um most of the major Assets in the
United States and actually globally are
on the coastline
from that standpoint the facilities are
as vulnerable as people's homes so
there's a lot of offshore infrastructure
in the Gulf of Mexico but that comes
onshore to a lot of pipelines that are
right at the coastline
and so as the coastline erodes those
pipelines become noticeable and
vulnerable and have to be
buried deeper or infrastructure put
around it to protect it
so indeed yeah hardening of
infrastructure you know utilities and
fires that have been associated with
that or the the pipelines people are
worried about how to protect those going
forward
nature is going to be eroding the
foundations of our economy
so sometimes I'm out in a place like
this
and I imagine what it would be like to
come here
with no money in my pocket
fleeing
an economic meltdown because you know
look we do have plenty of land
but if I had to survive out here
and didn't have the money
to buy something to provide me power
some way to get water
of a fairly dry land
while we love pristine nature and we
like to hike in it hunt in it camp in it
all those things we do
thanks to the technology that you bought
at the store
the tent
the gun the flashlight
the lighter
these things are made in human
communities in factories not by people
on the Run not by people out of capital
foreign
it's all about capital
so here's what happens capital is going
to flow to where it can make the most
money for the capital owner
a town like this which was a silver
mining town
is a good example of foraging Theory
where if you're an animal or you know
and these things translate into the
human world as well
and you've got a choice between two
things one that's easy to get and one
that's hard to get if the easy thing to
get is worth more that's what you're
going to go for so that's what produces
boom towns because at one point the
silver was really easy to get to and
worth something and then when the silver
market crashed well it wasn't worth
anything
so they moved on to find the next
easiest thing to mine
these patterns of capital
do not change over time
capital is always going to seek the
greatest return
and as soon as that return isn't paying
off it's going to pull up stakes and go
somewhere else
the the way to define capital is the
money that is going to be used
to create something people are very
myopic they are just looking at what's
in front of their face and the portfolio
that's right there how they're going to
make money in the short term
foreign
so you know look we look around and it's
like this is all this is all the capital
this is all the capital in the world
headquartered right here right and
I'm assuming they all want to live you
know past 2050 and so we got to change
over are they beating down uh are they
beating down a trail to your door to
invest
no they're not uh we have to search uh
for the right type of investors for our
projects
and the and when we do find the
investors for our projects it's
extremely difficult to create the value
or pull out the value for our projects
that the investors uh should recognize
immediately
if somebody can get 15 on their money
doing derivatives why would they want to
get five percent on their money doing
renewable
because they would be able to use the
investment tax credit everybody wants a
return and everybody wants to maximize
their return
and the only groups that I know can
maximize their return for renewable
energy projects today
are the wealthy individuals that have
passive income and what do we think of
as like wealthy individuals I think a
lot of Americans think if someone has
five hundred thousand dollars they're
well the individual and we're talking
about people who have hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars of net
worth so minimum 100 million dollars of
net worth I would say so but there's not
many people maybe less than one percent
of the population that has that type of
Investment Portfolio or investment
Investments uh the generating passive
income any more comments that's pretty
close all right pretty close Perfect all
right so when there's not investment in
the market towards the technology that
would help for climate Solutions and
Renewables and clean energy then that
trickles down into the entire
um
the entire life stream or life cycle you
know the whole flow of business
Lord Caine who was the founder of
macroeconomics asked the question why do
people invest and honestly there's no
answer he called it animal spirits
I can tell you people are risk averse
and after 2008 there are even more
risk-averse
when I go to these business conferences
and I see my friends ask the guy who's
worth a hundred million dollars I said
what are you working on now he says you
know he said I'm just um I'm pretty
happy where I am and um you know I've
got uh I've got the house in Mexico and
uh and we're looking after the grandkids
and I mean he's not investing in taking
risks he's not creating jobs for the
rest of us at least not directly that's
the animal spirits that are out there
and too much of the business Community
right now so the only way you can
replace that is with government
leadership
the Erie Canal the Transcontinental
Railroad the Panama Canal the space
program the interstate highway system
in no case did a group of entrepreneurs
get together and say hey let's build the
interstate highway system
no it was a dream that Ike pushed in
1955 that came from a study done during
World War II that showed that you needed
these highways for national security
problems this is no partisan policy no
one has a
a a monopoly on truth and on the facts
that affect this country we must work
together
the United States is highly
disaggregated we have uh you know 50
states One Nation many counties many
regions tens of thousands of cities they
all have a voice in how things are done
and it's hard to get us to collaborate
on certain projects unless we all align
and agree it's necessary and we feel
some urgency to get it done
if your Australian military has studied
the U.S military study and the British
military study are all correct we've got
about 30 years if we don't do anything
until civilization collapses
which I'm guessing doesn't have a good
rate of return
correct so so Wes there are actually
those
um who would tell you that we may be
Beyond The Tipping Point already I'm I
don't subscribe to that by the way uh if
if you do subscribe to that then it
almost makes the investment in you know
wind and solar not pertinent
[Music]
what's the most valuable thing in the
world the most valuable thing
its oil reserves in the ground
it's worth more than the GDP of the
United States more than the stock market
more than the stock markets of all the
Western countries
it's oil in the ground
and the people that have that oil
they want it to be used
whatever you hear about Saudi Arabia
saying they're going to you know have
moved Beyond a petrol based economy yeah
yeah but they're going to move at their
pace and they need those petrol dollars
to get there the societal costs right
now are much greater than the economic
costs of taking it out of the ground
so you have to recognize the societal
impact and you have to make the people
who are producing it and selling it and
the people who are buying it
pay the full cost of using it
and that that means a tax but we didn't
we didn't even do that with security
though because I mean realistically
we've subsidized the oil industry for 50
years by knocking over governments by
protecting shipping lanes for it oil
Lanes so we couldn't even do it when it
came to like
having them pay for their own extraction
and security
it's true but one of the reasons we
couldn't do it is because we didn't
really have the alternative
sound we didn't we didn't really have
the alternative technically
[Music]
Engineers worked Under Fire to douse oil
pipelines set Ablaze by retreating Iraqi
troops
animal fats and Tallow could no longer
Supply the ever-growing need for candles
and lubricants
[Music]
which had long been the chief illuminant
was becoming scarce yet the demand for
artificial light was increasing in 1850
a lamp capable of efficiently burning a
refined product of petroleum was
invented
early oil production they used steam
power for the drilling for the riggings
a different piece of equipment and that
seam power probably was produced by
burning water coal so you'd use wood or
coal to get oil today we use electricity
to get oil we use gas to get oil so we
use one form of energy to get another
and that's one of the interconnected
aspects of energy that's kind of
surprising for people is how
interdependent it is we don't have an
economy that runs on one form of energy
we have an economy that runs on many
forms
foreign
part of this equation certainly in the
short term to this time period you're
worried about is modulating consumption
and adjusting cultural Behavior but
people aren't talking about that no one
wants to blame anybody if you want to
blame industry well industry exists
because people buy their things or use
their things so they're the ultimate
consumers are we going to carbon tax
them are we going to punish them or
maybe part of the equation is we all
accept responsibility and we get a
cultural change to take place here to go
back to where we were 20 or 30 or 40
years ago but that's hard the vast
majority of our individual impact comes
from housing transport and food these
are kind of big structural issues that
can't really be addressed adequately by
changing the brand of paper towels you
buy we we live in an energy consumption
Society
and
the way to look at things we have to be
aware that nothing comes for free
you have to be aware that everything
costs energy whatever you do
[Music]
this is not what public space looks like
in the U.S because but I noticed here in
the Netherlands everybody's riding bikes
everywhere they are yeah and that
doesn't strangely require uh
gasoline nope
[Music]
the question is can we
replace
fossil fuel through the renewable energy
and this is a very tricky question
it raises enormous
debates and people get angry
when you ask them this question because
it is not clear what you mean
if you mean that you can satisfy
people's greed with renewable energy
that their service now
if you mean renewable energy could
produce
a sufficient amount of energy
in order to survive and the answer is
yes we are in an energy efficient home
now that we've rebuilt that
our household use
alone is twice the size of the average
American
that woke me up I can't count the number
of trips that I've taken around the
world for business
but that two International trips
uh was equal to one year of utility
energy in my home and that really had me
thinking about
travel it had me thinking about
would I eat
foreign
for many people is how much energy we
use in the food system and complete
dinners in the United States we use 100
quadrillion BTU of energy a year BTU is
a British thermal unit one BTU is about
the energy content of a kitchen match so
in the United States we use 100 billion
million kitchen matches of energy per
year
10 quads 10 quadromeo 2 is for the food
system one of those quads is in the food
itself food is a form of energy we're
ingesting one quad of food energy into
our bodies for 330 million Americans
every year the other nine quads is for
the rest of the food system this is in
the agrochemicals the fertilizers and
pesticides diesel for tractors the
energy for refrigeration the energy for
drying crops the silos warehouses
Transportation plus the energy to cook
at our homes pies are done three or four
quads of that is just for the cold chain
that's the refrigeration system
refrigerated trucks refrigerated
warehouses and refrigerators and
freezers at our homes and businesses
the energy embedded in the cold chain of
the food system in the United States is
more energy than entire countries like
Switzerland and Sweden consume in a year
combined
the energy embedded in the edible food
we throw away is also enough to power
entire countries elsewhere
sadly we throw away like a fourth to
half of our edible food
[Music]
okay so Michael here we are we're
surrounded by water yeah and what's the
relationship between water and energy
the water energy relationship is twofold
one is we use a lot of water for energy
we use water to cool power plants we use
water to irrigate biofuels we use water
for oil and gas production we use water
to make Steam at refineries in fact if
you look all up and down the energy
supply chain Waters at every step
our well went dry dead yeah it's dead
this is where the water that would be
the full Mark it's not a fantasy
Apocalypse movie landscape it's now and
it's real
so the grid might be strained if you
don't have water available for cooling
at least the way we have most power
plants today where they use heat they
then need the water for cooling modern
forms of like solar panels and wind
turbines don't need water coolings the
average life for PV panels is what 20
years 20 25 years yeah 20 25 years so
maybe 30 years yeah so the people say
well it takes seven years of energy to
to produce this PV panel but then you're
getting that means you're getting 18
years of energy free so yeah cut down
even then you get eight and yes energy
for free yeah yeah so mean John Q public
I'm like hey man I want to put some
money into your solar farm no not not
until not until the government gets
involved with uh things puts us into a
Perry pursue position with fossil fuels
got a lot of friends here and are in the
renewable business and there's a really
big problem in terms of you know you've
got the power purchase agreement you've
got all the permitting done you've even
got interconnect agreements except
what's happening is grid companies are
delaying and not letting them on the
grid what's what's going on with that I
think one of the challenges we have is
who has access to the infrastructure and
democratizing the infrastructure is a
way to open it up so that more solutions
can be brought forward this is something
we did with telecommunications in the
80s with ATT had built out all the wires
and poles and they were required to open
up their infrastructure for other
companies and that's why we have so many
phone companies and long distance
companies now that we didn't have before
the same thing could happen with
democratizing the electrical
infrastructure more solutions would be
plugged in more wind is solar and we
have more Technologies along the way and
this is where long range planning stable
governments really matter
kind of what I'm hearing is it's it's
not a technology problem no it's not an
engineering problem no it's a financial
engineering problem
energy poverty lack of food income
inequality so it's up to us now to form
the policy that is going to help bridge
this Gap in 1941 when the United States
went to war people saved tin cans and
aluminum and and gave up women gave up
buying nylon stockings and everything
was done for the war effort but the war
was there was right in front of us and
young men were being drafted and sent
overseas and casualties were coming home
and this is different
it requires the same type of
reorganization or commitment but why
didn't they call
[Music]
[Music]
them that was then and this is now check
out our new lot the OK Solutions lot
with millions of new Solutions and more
coming every single day looking for
something that's easy and in your price
range check out our pre-owned Solutions
like changing a light bulb or walking to
work or our mid-size selections like
regenerative agriculture or a price on
carbon or you'll love a variety of brand
new Solutions with that brand new
solution smell like deleveraging climate
risk from the derivatives Market or the
million mile battery which is coming
soon just listen to one of our satisfied
customers Michael you are now in charge
of the United States energy policy and
you have free reign how would we make
the transition for national security
reasons and for economic reasons and for
environmental reasons there are many
reasons to do this we need to harden
improve and expand our grid maybe even
using the interstate highways we already
have the rights away and put lines above
ground our below ground create a
national network and then it will span
and reach to the sunny windy areas in
order to connect to the urban areas
once we have the network we can plug in
whatever we want build the
infrastructure first then the energy
will follow but we have to put a price
on pollution we'll take the money from
the price on pollution to pay to clean
up the trash so let's take the United
States six billion tons of CO2 a year
put in the atmosphere and let's say
we're willing to pay I don't know 30 a
ton to remove it that works out too if I
do my math correctly 180 billion dollars
a year sounds like a lot of money that's
less than what we spend on just dealing
with trash from cities
why not spend another cup on our
building cleaning up the waste in the
atmosphere
let's take the CO2 and put it into the
soil like let's pay Farmers to take CO2
out of the atmosphere into the soil
[Music]
we need to get more of that National
Security mindset
if you have a built to last strategy
then you do want to look at
what's happening in these longer
Horizons and it's absolutely critical
it's going to take all forms of energy
and all people to move us through this
transition otherwise in I don't think we
actually stand a chance
[Music]
I'm trying to get rid of this car but
it's like quitting smoking you know it's
not easy you are so used to certain
things that that it is very difficult
[Music]
the Romans
had done a lot of bad things to the
ecosystem yeah yeah but
they had not destroyed it as we could do
FEMA estimates for every dollar spent on
Hazard mitigation you save four dollars
in Disaster Recovery costs
um so we're already spending the money
there's a sense that it's you know
perhaps too expensive to prepare for
climate change
but we we are already spending the money
we're spending it after every disaster
hits
[Music]
you know when I was growing up it was
the draft so everybody thought they had
an obligation to the country if you went
to a land-grant college you were drafted
now it's uh it's different
the Trust In government's gone
the obligation to government is gone if
we could take some of that Spirit of
patriotism and service and rebuild it
into doing something for the environment
this entire thing is built out of carbon
that comes out of the atmosphere
[Music]
you need a hundred thousand young people
to give up part of their summer and form
up and really work this we could control
these pine beetles that are destroying
the forest we could plant new trees but
it should be done not only for pay as a
guaranteed job but it should also be
done for every citizens obligation to
take care of the land
that's what I'd like to see sounds like
you should inspire a whole generation of
people too it sounds like something that
all guys would say
pregnant baby
that's a good noise
made me want to be more of a fighter for
her sake the transformation is is
potentially exciting
um because we can think not only about
losing things that we have always wanted
but also letting go of things that we
perhaps don't benefit from
um we can we can lose in order to
transform into something else it's not
it's not as kind of confident that
things will be okay but but it finds
possibility in the ways that the things
will have to change and kind of really
dramatic ways
and so we are looking at diversifying
the types of crops that we are wanting
to plant and and also work with
conservation type programs to help
preserve species and habitat and let let
nature take its course and and bring
back species that that we need and that
the crops actually need to be productive
[Music]
foreign
we don't want a hurricane or a tropical
storm or they're already geared up the
crops are turned in they want to go
ahead and get finished people want to
know where their food came from well at
some point maybe people want to know
where their Banker lives and who he is
and do I have a relationship with him to
when I need some money to fix something
I can maybe find somebody to help me
I mean it's not a matter of the
government telling Banks what to do or
telling us what we can do no I mean
there's still lots of possibilities
we should have smaller Banks basically
split them up
and not make them too big to fail if
they make mistakes they should fail
without causing a total systems crisis
and probably what also needs to be done
is introduce rules which make it
impossible for the financial sector to
create within the financial sector
itself
so much additional debt
we have to somehow correct this Market
imperfection if you want to have a
derivative if you want to hedge your
risk fine but you must have exposure to
the underlying asset
I I remember I was watching on TV after
a major flood down in Florida and they
were interviewing this guy and he said
my father rebuilt twice my grandfather
rebuilt twice and he says and I'm going
to rebuild again and the reporter turned
to the camera and said that's the
American way well
I thought the reporter should say that's
stupid
you can't keep doing it over and over
again that's the definition of insanity
[Music]
so it's basically trust in the monetary
management and Trust in the future
productivity of a country that gives us
trust in the currency not the idea that
there are some gold Barons hidden in the
Federal Reserve
and so there is a point of resistance at
which you know governments aren't going
to be uh have had access to Capital to
address the problem
we're rich
you know the fear is if we cannot bail
out the system anymore it will come
crashing down with huge side effects
The Hope and that sounds a little
cynical but I think the hope is we
probably can reorder our system only
after a crash I think human history
suggests that we are unable to make
really fundamental change in the way we
live and the way we organize ourselves
without such a crush nobody wants it and
I'm the last person who wants it if I
think back to the 1930s and I'm German
right and you think about what the
repercussions of the major crisis can be
um we just don't know how we will get
out on the other end of the tunnel I
think without this crisis I just don't
see enough political leverage to
fundamentally alter the way we organize
our financial system
when climate change happens
there will be real problems and there
will be real as you said and there will
be real scarcities and there will be
real migrants coming and there will be
and and and that's what I and then we'll
really be broke because it'll be after
you've had that collapse of the inverted
pyramid and then it's like then it's
like asking Somalia to fight climate
change
so your criticism would be that we're
not facing reality and not adapting to
it that's correct my answer to that is I
still have faith in democracy I believe
we can do it as a people I believe we
can do it as a society and I believe we
can take the institutions of the United
States that have served this country
very well for over 200 years and move
into the 21st century and still help
leave mankind forward
it's an Article of Faith but it's the
faith that motivates action
we have almost all the tools and all the
financial resources and all the
institutions that could solve this
problem it's the kind of challenge that
could bring mankind together in a way
we've never been brought together before
[Music]
I wish there was more conversation you
know more more guys on the opposite side
talking together because everybody as we
feel they're people feeling opposite
from us that are just as righteous and
all of that stuff but we ought to get
together to see the thing is if you get
together with people like this what you
find is the disagreements are pretty
narrow actually yes that's what I mean
people are mostly agreed on like 95 yeah
but but there are forces in the culture
that that want to sharpen and and and
popularize those disagreements yeah it's
a human nature issue okay so what sells
tell me what sells what do you pay
attention to when it's happening around
you gotta find people conflict conflict
truth conflict true that's it to create
that kind of uh dialogue between a
father and a son that love thing you
know I mean this is my kid you know you
guys must have some wild conversations
man until it gets me know
I totally disagree with you no I
disagree with that
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]